I introduced weird tropical fruit to
people from every corner of the world
it's the most amazing thing there's
sugar apples I don't
I got a Monsanto's Sabadell is the
sweetest fruit it's like a pear with
brown sugar it's just a religious
experience eating this fruit this is
Robert right here and here here he is
and here my name is Robert bowling and I
own Robert is here a little bit of a
landmark here for over 60 years at six
years old Robert started selling regular
produce my dad was farming down in South
Florida and he was not doing as well as
could have been done so his dad put up a
sign that said Robert is here as a
marketing technique and Robert is still
here
customers stop for the cute kid and
stayed for the great fruit death kept on
farming till I was about 14 and then he
sold all of his equipment didn't farm
anymore and about 14 I bought this
property I worked on my farm by myself
doing most of the tractor work and
spring and everything else now we have
about 50 acres of land farm animals
booming fruit stand and a great crew
ever since a neighbor introduced Robert
to fruit Cecropia mango and guanabana
Robert fell in love with the exotic
flavors and wanted to share them with
anyone who came to a stand we have
jackfruit can Estelle mom would see us
which is a Spanish wine rambutan light
cheese and long hands other guanabana
yes there's so many
[Music]
South Florida is one of the only
climates that can grow so many tropical
fruits all in one place today Robert can
sell up to 50 varieties at one time when
it's in season
everything's grown right here what was
once a small operation is now a family
business and for Robert sharing his
passion with his family has made all the
difference the whole family is on the
market now running it I worked really
hard and I want my family to work really
hard and still have fun my aim is to be
the best farm market ever on the planet
and I'm not far from it
you